now we're doing cold reads uh and I need
bed you and Max okay simmer Please
Mr Keating asks for simmer they were
done by the late 90s
all right whenever you're ready
how the have you been great
why is there no furniture here Tim is
moving thanks for returning my phone
calls you dick sorry I've only been back
for like four days been I don't know I
but I've been looking for you well here
I am what can I do for you dude what
have you got what did you take up there
well in hardcore Center writing course
this music course music course did you
write any music yeah a little hey I got
some lyrics
write some music we'll make millions
millions of what
are you going back are you gonna stay
and play in LA where
Jesus to school you jerk I don't know I
suppose so you suppose so yeah
cute scarf real cute guess Blair still
likes you
I guess you guess you guess
it's good how about a gram here you go
dude keep your money Christmas present
okay
thanks a lot rip
I think you should go back don't
off don't be a bum like you like me dude
I don't know if I want to what do you
mean you don't know if you don't if you
want to I don't know things are
different here listen you've got a long
vacation don't you a month right yeah
four weeks
a month right
think about it I'll do that
okay good short and sweet but you know
if you do you do it peace simmer please
guys you do a piece like this on a on a
hit TV show you do a short scene like
that remember no small rolls just small
actors you can't have stinking thinking
you know
do the gig
do a great job do your best commit the
rest forget about it okay yeah you know
yeah good it's there's a lot in this
piece
so don't ever look at a two and a half
or three page piece and don't think oh I
mean I never thought that I know
it's a it's a reminder for everybody you
know it's just a reminder for everybody
okay uh Blake you want her to work next
Blake and Kenny
I don't give you line readings and I
don't tell you what to expect that's
your job
do you bring your soul to the character
that's why they hired you they hired you
because when you auditioned you gave
them something that they were looking
for
you know don't go there to please them
or anything go there Pacino says act
it's your chance to act
go there and kick ass
you know
don't give them what you think they want
you know why they don't know what they
want
you know if I was up for a role in a
feature film that shot in the midwest a
couple years ago
and and I'm white white-haired white
bearded and six three and they went with
a five foot two Chinese guy obviously
they didn't know what they were looking
for
and I know my audition was very good
because the director told me it was very
good so they don't know they don't
always know
so you can't take anything personally
it's totally subjective
you know if you're a blonde and a
beautiful woman and you go to an
audition and the directors
ex-wife is blonde and beautiful and he
hates her guts you're not going to get
the role is that fair no is life no
okay
there you go I learned something new
today I learned that in 1905 a hundred
thousand dollars
was a hundred thousand dollars but today
it's the equivalent of three million
so when the Rockefellers and the
Kennedys and all those people were doing
illegal to make all their Millions
it was because
that's how much that money was worth
then stop and think about it
and a loaf of bread was a nickel
or cheaper
are we ready
ready ready in the booth
okay cool listos
anytime
grades came today Todd
yeah I know
1B
4 C's One D
oh d
for Christ sakes Todd your mother's not
showing it but she's really upset uh-huh
I got you've never got a report like
this a d
in beginning algebra what what is this I
don't know Dad
all right your mother and I think you
spent too much time with Mr Denker we
think you should cut down the time you
spend on the weekends
no Dad please don't please on that
something it's my fault I mean he'd be
lost without me I'll do better really
that algebra just threw me to start with
I just messed up it won't happen again
you're spending way too much time with
him Mr stormman the algebra teacher is
really hard lots of kids get these three
or four
I won't go on Wednesdays anymore and
they'll study extra hot hard
I really like the old guy that much
he's really Indian tells great stories
plus he needs companionship
okay
I'm just thinking of your future
you know junior high is not too soon to
start thinking about it but for now
try it your way thanks Steph and I
promise I'll work extra hard
and cut okay a lot in the piece how old
is this character Junior High School
yeah junior high school so it's
important so it's important that you
finish
okay it must be my son you only did you
know when you said me you get an
operating on me and and that very end
your last line you give me an up where
you don't no upbring never doing upward
guys remember go through your script
take out that punctuation writers write
the way writers write they don't write
the way people speak
so it's your job to look at the copy at
the words
and extrapolate the meaning
you know exclamation point most Bad
actors think that means you have to yell
or exaggerate don't do that
when you know a question mark do I say
David how are you today no is how are
you today it's a question
if it's written as a question and you
make it a statement is going to sound
like a question
leave it alone just leave it alone
take out the periods we don't talk
period that that period that that that
period we don't do that geez my whole
life is one long run on sentence you
know that's the way we talk
so just be careful only twice though and
that's the first time tonight so good
for you keep working on it kiddo you've
got it both connection nice
good dad
let's see uh Jill and Felix
you do
[Music]
you do Joel you have a scene okay
it's ours babe
I'm putting in a teardrop window
what do you mean
if it's worse
traded her in
don't worry I got this below sale
price Super Deal
you know about it three days ago but
there was some paperwork
surprise
you bought this thing without even
telling me they installed these windows
for you at the dealership but it's like
a rip-off you know I'm saving about a
hundred and a half
you like it I mean come on do you like
it you and I are going on our belated
cross-country honeymoon trip first week
of August
I I just can't pick up and go on a
three-week vacation I only get one week
vacation no it's all taken care of I I
called what's his face you know your
boss right and he finally agreed to give
you a week with pay plus two weeks off
without pay
you planned a vacation without even
asking well you know I'm putting in the
shag carpet down on the floor you know
Boomers got a Remnant left from their
place all the Comforts of home huh like
come on what's not to like about it well
come on say something
uh uh
um I thought you were going to write
poems all summer you
said that's what you needed to do
travel will feed my writing you know
Feed the Beast I figured you can take
the wheel when I drive and I just
I thought you'd be excited about it
I don't know I think it was easy putting
all this together
but a lot of that money was my
grandmother she gave it to us
oh okay I get it I get it yeah all right
yeah hands off of the wedding stash
because she's my grandmother not yours
never realized you're such a
materialist before Little Miss equity
that's not the point how about this man
whatever whatever the her name is
doesn't doesn't she get her usual vote
in this too
look I wanted to surprise you with this
honeymoon we never got to have not that
our marriage needs a jump start or
anything not that we have any room for
any wedded bliss
and that's it
you got it that's it
[Laughter]
Andrea and Kai
you need to get my chakra
and yes Kai
yes Kai I know you're not a grandfather
but
Lou Gossett Jr started playing
grandfathers when he was 30. so I
figurative Lou Gossett could do it you
could do it
they aged him
yeah because because he was capable of
doing it in a very similar please and a
very good friend of mine who just got an
Oscar for writing uh
couple years ago Kevin Wilmot who's a
fabulous actor he in one of his early
films that he wrote and shot in Kansas
City he played 39th Street it was a
history of 39th Street which was where
all the black bars were in Lawrence
Kansas uh
during World War II
he played a grandfather in that and he
was at that time probably only 35-38
so yeah I mean that's why we're actors
isn't it
you know
I don't want a real job
hi Grandpa
what's going on I have something to tell
you
what's wrong
I need to tell you something okay what
is it
back 20 years before your grandma died
we decided to put some money back for
you kids so you have down payment for
your home
it's in 30 month CDs
last three times it matured
I wanted to give it to you kids but
your mother won't let me
promise me
something should happen to me you'll get
it
I'm surprised mom even let you've been
wanting CDs for us to begin with
and how they should find out
I have to Lisa got remarried I had to
change with a new married name
it came in the mail with a name on it
and care of me
I can't walk to the mailbox anymore so
your mother found out when she picked
him up there
I bet I went over like a little balloon
she wasn't very happy
she said you kids didn't need it she
said the boys are both as an alcohol
drug to women
Lisa's husband would end up would end up
with all hers and
you and Debbie just didn't need it all
Grandpa what in the world happened to
your arm
that is where your mom hit me
oh my God was that last Sunday a little
Skippy birthday party
okay I call over just after she had done
it and she had the nerve to tell me
about it
if I had been there I don't know what I
would have done
there is no excuse for a 55 year old
woman to hit an 85 year old period no
excuse at all and I told her so
what did she say
she reminded me the time I broke my
mother's finger
time she went around telling everyone
should have done it
yeah that's the time
she was coming at me and you know how
she throws these hands up to grab you
well I threw up mine to blockers and our
fingers interlaced
I guess being scared to death gave me a
strength and I didn't know I had
and I just snapped her finger
Grandpa maybe and I discussed have
discussed that and we think we should
have Mom come here no
as any trouble your long bills at the
grocery store for me he picks up my mail
every day I don't want to stir up
anything
I've already forgiven her but
I'll never forget what she did as long
as I live okay grandpa but if it happens
again you won't have any choice we will
have her committed she bit us she bit us
kids every day of Our Lives
and she's not starting on you
She's Dangerous Grandpa
I don't think you should know how
dangerous
okay there's a lot in this piece so when
you memorize it
you can do it you can do it man you you
can do it I know you can do it two
things lead balloon fled yeah lead
balloon and then when you when Jill send
you the material that you did tonight in
your earlier piece that you did with Mr
uh bedroom uh look at the the in take
one look at where you talk about
wallowing it dig it and look at the
difference in your transition the second
take on those same lines because
it's really interesting I want you to
see the difference in the take one and
take two just in that sequence okay yeah
you'll see and tell me what you see okay
good uh let's see uh Rochelle and Mr CMS
uh
whenever you're ready
what the hell is going on John
Janice you're trembling I
I knew that funeral last week must have
been unbearable for you
and Sarah let me write you a
prescription for a sedative it'll help
you calm down I don't want a sedative I
want some answers
you and Jack have been best friends
since College you and I both know Jack
was as healthy as a horse he had never
been sick a day in his life there was
never any history of heart problems in
Jack's family
and yet you expect me to believe that he
actually died from a heart attack Janice
you've read the autopsy report the U.S
attorney general conducted a formal
investigation
it's over Janice I'm sorry
don't you find it odd that Janet will
fly out to conduct a personal
investigation
especially for some small small town
Memphis lawyer Jack was no small town
lawyer he was a partner in one of the
largest firms in Memphis how much did
Jack tell you about why he was about
what he was working on
well he told me that he had an upcoming
trip to to blightsville and he said that
he wanted to conduct his own
investigation I mean Christ why why
couldn't that husband of yours be
satisfied with staying inside the
courtroom why did he always have to be
Dick Tracy too
John
Jack called that money that Monday from
Blytheville
he found what he was looking for
he told me that he didn't think he would
make it out alive
he was right
John I'm afraid
I'm afraid for my life and for Sarahs
you know it's a matter of National
Security and you know that such
Preposterous conclusions not be released
to the press such conclusions you know
could harm the president's image as well
as ruin your career to save you from any
further embarrassment and whatever you
know I'm relieving you of your duties
those were her exact words I mean it
didn't make sense at the time but oh boy
now it does
what did Jack die from anthrax
what is anthrax Anthrax is a steroid
used on cattle ranchers use it to
produce meteor livestock you know a
research team at UT Martin found out
that when when it was injected into
smaller animals It produced heart
failures
you know because it's a steroid the uh
the heart attack occurs naturally unless
you're specifically looking for traces
of the steroid no doctors would ever
know that it wasn't a heart attack
how did you know to look for the drug
John
I put together the research team at UT
Martin
bad dude
you're right
Adam and Mr Keating
my associate tells me you alluded to me
as a first class jerk
I didn't want you I didn't want to use
stronger language in front of them I
never liked
to see a robot blush
what exactly do you want they also told
me you referred to me as a Becky
not a term of endearment prefer not to
be called a Becky oh yeah
thank you
fine
why why am I here that's precisely what
I'm most anxious to learn
what does bring you to London
personal business
you may recall that I didn't care for
you when you were a California police
officer and come poking around in London
some years ago
yeah
I find it I find
I care for you even less right now
right now that you're nothing more than
a private investigator
I dislike you about the same as I did
back seven years ago
no more no less
the Sun and soldier case is one I don't
want anyone interfering with
well now
you don't have any jurisdiction in
France don't try playing the schoolboy
games
you're much too far along and you're
supering off Garden to bring it off
cardigan there's been a killing yeah
right here in England I assumed you
already knew that
isn't that why you came over to England
in such a rush
no it isn't
who's the victim
Senator Ainsworth
it was murdered outside the apartment of
his current mistress
his Sky car pilot was only shot with a
stun gun
Ainsworth of course was killed by having
his body quartered
do all the details match the other
killings the description of the killers
match
this method was the same
unless something's bothering me
I know you've been hired to look into
the murder of Joseph but
Joseph
are they really any indications that he
wasn't a victim of the unknown soldier
soldier
some yeah
I know he left last night contained A
variation
which was
in addition to his usual message he
added a PostScript
instead of one word
true
which can mean that this was a true
Unknown Soldier kill and not an
imitation
you're fairly convinced there are two
separate killers
there seems to be
there's the Unknown Soldier and there's
the Kathy cop copycat who did it in
Bouchon
look
you give me your word you're not here to
interfere with this investigation
until you told me
I didn't even know there had been a new
Killing where are you staying
the Crystal Palace Hotel
you may consider our interview at an end
okay
so they're Kippy cut
yeah
it's okay
okay so so gentlemen
you can be much more dismissive
and upset that he's in your
territory again right
do you have positional Authority
he's there nosing around
so
let him know that okay okay
and you just don't give a
you're following up on a lead you had
and you don't care what he thinks about
you being there Max and Gene
no good Max injury hey guys this is just
a note for everybody uh if you're not
cold reading aloud 30 minutes every day
I can tell
I don't care if I'm ever in front of a
camera again
although I did enjoy doing the film I
did two years ago
but
I still cold read a lot 30 minutes every
day I have every day since 1970.
I do it because I won't ask you to do
something I'm not willing to do
but I can only suggest that you do it I
can't force you to do it
but I do know after 70 plus years of
being a working actor not just someone
walking around with a script under my
arm saying I'm a bartender but I want to
be an actor a working actor I know how
important these skills are because
you've heard me say this before and
Jeannie wrote it in her her new writings
that she wrote your craft will support
you when your knees won't
and it's important that you understand
that this is a business guys like any
other business if you don't stay on top
of your stuff
somebody else will come by and Gobble
you up there's always a faster gun in
the West
okay
remember that
Jenny do
why are we making small talk gem when
you're troubled
I know something's wrong
can you just please tell me what it is
darling
I want to know what's bothering you
I suppose there's no putting it off
I had a bit of a set too with Winston
today again
is that all
I mean you've had clashes with him
before and they always blow over so this
will just I've resigned you've resigned
as managing editor of the company that
is effective immediately
why
and why didn't you mention it to me and
tell me what was on your mind I mean I
simply don't understand
I didn't think I was going to resign
until I did
Jim this is perfectly ridiculous just
because you had a little row with
Winston doesn't mean you have to do
something as drastic as this as dramatic
I mean after all Grandy has the final
word you know that
she appointed you and and she'll
reinstate you at once and and she'll put
Winston straight deal with him
look I'll
I'll speak with her tomorrow ring her
first thing in the morning and it'll
just all be
I'm afraid you're misunderstanding me
Winston didn't force me to resign or
anything like that
if that's what you're thinking I did so
of my own accord I wanted to and rather
badly although I must admit in Ultra
thinness I didn't realize this until the
opportunity presented itself
so I certainly don't want to be
reinstated but why not For Heaven's Sake
because I don't like the job
never have when Winston came to me to
means morning I asked I asked Point
Blank if I would if I wished to continue
as managing the director and as he was
speaking I knew really knew Paula that I
didn't
I've never been particularly good at
administrative work or interested in it
and I told Winston so and he said he
sends he sends this for some time
he pointed out that perhaps it would be
better if I stuck to journalism
I ran papers for the for the company
I thoroughly agree with him so I stepped
down
that's all there is to it actually
oh there is to it
that I'm hearing you say these things
you're acting as though it doesn't
matter as if this wasn't serious when
it's terribly serious
and you're being so Cavalier so
dismissive I am absolutely staggered
don't get so ahead up frankly I'm felt
relief
relief should be the last thing on your
mind
I mean what about Duty what about
responsibility you know Granny showed a
great deal of faith in you put her trust
in you when when when she appointed you
to manager director last year
and I think that you've let her down
rather badly I'm sorry you feel that way
well
because I must disagree with
I haven't like Randy down
I'm still going to be managing editor in
charge of two the most important
newspaper in the Consolidated group
I'll be doing
your best being a newspaper man and a
damn good one at that
who's gonna run the company now that
you've stepped down
instant
very well
he doesn't want that job
neither do I
hope this sudden and rather
extraordinary decision of yours doesn't
mean that Grandy will have to cancel her
trip with Blackie
she really needs this holiday
what did she say I mean I presume that
you've already told her naturally I've
told her
Winston Knights walked over to the store
at lunch time for a meeting with her
your grandmother accepted my rest my
resignation
Winston's agreed to take the job and he
didn't seem very perturbed about the
idea either Grandy isn't going to cancel
her holiday rest assured of that come on
relax
you're the one who's more upset than
anyone
Randy and Winston respect my decision
they didn't quibble
in fact there was very little discussion
it was rather cut and dried actually
I think you've simply misunderstood
their reactions now you're being
ridiculous Paula
I I know them both very well and I can
assure you that everything is all right
for your sake it is
dude it's a wonderful piece wow not row
row is a British term for argument
around so if you want to change it to
argument
oh do I say that yeah
you said bro
somewhere in their page two I middle of
page two I think but it's not like I
know all the material I just know all
the materials
but it's somewhere in the middle of page
two okay guys uh look
um
some really good work tonight you know
you know you should feel all all of you
should feel really good about uh
everything that was done look it it's
just consistency
you've got to keep doing it oh I don't
have the money I can't do that I can't
but you can go to Starbucks every day
and spend eight bucks on a cup of coffee
you know I'm not telling you how to
spend your money
I'm just telling you not you especially
Moneybags
I know but no giveaways when we have
guests because the oh that guests might
have won maybe we should have done a
giveaway no I'm just saying you know
that it's it's doing it and doing it and
doing it you're going to have plateaus
that's why I ask everybody that starts
here to buy the book Mastery by George
Leonard and read it if you've been here
longer than a week and you haven't
purchased that it's free online
get it online for free read the damn
book it's only 124 Pages it only costs
14.95 I think if you want to buy it but
it's free
you know and if you don't have money
there's a library nearby that you know
check it out at the library oh I didn't
have a library card get one they're free
you know it's like Jill says about cold
reading all the time don't spend 800 on
a cold reading class I have two separate
sheets of paper and five minutes of my
time I will gladly give you 15 minutes
20 minutes 30 minutes and teach on a
cold read for free
but cold readers are skill that you have
to develop
working on your craft daily is something
you have to develop I say it all the
time and then I'll say good night
dancers dance and stretch every day
whether they're working or not
singers vocalize and sing every day
musicians play their instrument every
day
whether they're working or not and
actors sit on their ass and wait for the
phone to ring and if you're one of those
actors when the phone rings guess what
you are not ready
so I want you to be ready I want you to
be prepared the Chinese symbols
for
opportunity and preparation when put
together our success
now that's a that's a diagrammatic
language that's over 6 000 years old
they knew something
because it's still true
if you're not prepared when the
opportunity arises you don't get the
brass ring
you keep missing it
there it is there it is there's a great
Tchaikovsky quote
um Tchaikovsky you know wrote 1812
Overture Romeo and Juliet
Nutcracker Swan Lake Sleeping Beauty
ballet just a couple things yeah
um so he's qualified
he said inspiration is a guest that does
not willingly visit the lazy
on that note everybody
have a great night be safe stay healthy
be well and thank you both David and
Karen so much for being here tonight I
hope you got something worthwhile I
don't know thank you a little dragon